who in particular in your life was the
most excited when they found that you
guys went to be in a Godzilla movie my
mom oh yeah yeah cuz she was just like
finally you know yo just straight out of
Compton yet it was like the family feel
for me boy this is why I got into movies
you know I got into movies for stuff to
blow up for me to look cool and it be
with my heroes like Godzilla Godzilla
was really excited he was like I'm
really happy you're part of my biopic
yeah anyway talk to you see you at lunch
tomorrow babe and it was you know he's
very Hollywood now and in the Godzilla
movies I'm used to watching a lot of the
old ones you know the range of acting is
mostly just screaming and running away
there's a lot of rehearsal for that or a
lot of prep for screaming running
Windows really weeks
we practiced our screams and are running
away I've got mine perfected it's it's
cool
of course cuz you know what you're a
part of play it's some long days when
you've been not only in wind and rain
for four days straight so that means the
feet are nice and pruned but then the
next week you have to run in epson salt
salt and so YUM yeah so you know that's
uh that's what we do for y'all for the
art so who are your characters in this
new movie I play Chief Warrant Officer
Barnes I am the senior officer of G team
which is the military group created by
monarch who kind of come back in to
handle these these monsters these
creatures and so being the the senior
officer I lose a couple of soldiers
along the way but you know we'll be
alright
I play Sam Coleman and the
communications liaison to monarch the
agency that monitors all the monsters
how was the crowd reaction out there in
comic-con sets everything that you guys
would feel so far dead silent it was no
a lot of walkouts no it was incredible
yeah and they went crazy for all the
right parts and even parts that I
because I'm not as well versed in
Godzilla but they're all picking up on
all these Easter eggs and all these
little bits and dissecting every frame
now there's social media is going crazy
yes it's been pretty cool I mean that's
like comic-con is the place to show a
movie like this where it's got a big big
franchise potential and a lot of history
to it and it's it's been positive it's
also the place to you know formulate
some dream matches so we got juice Momoa
as Aquaman out here who would win in a
big dream match battle Godzilla or
Aquaman oh well got to get out with this
question all the wheels all the sharks
and fish in the world
yeah can't help you against the g-man
and it's all right you know he's located
kwatak so they probably would talk it
out right but no problem I'm thinking
even if they take it to the water God so
I mean that's how he travels like what
you mean all right SummerSlam
predictions SummerSlam come up off that
belt
we want our belt back it's about time
that raw got their belt back Smackdown I
can't have just one show holding the
title so we need our belt back Brock
Lesnar loses at SummerSlam
holla at you man I play no games
definitive definitive